you're watching the daily climate show
on sky
news on today's programme a new normal
the
stark images showing how the us is
heating up
as areas of california experience
historic droughts
we find out how british banks support
for the coal industry has increased
despite global commitments to move away
from fossil fuels
and saving our seas and the carbon
stored in them
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
now the new normal is a phrase we've all
heard plenty of times during the last
year in relation to the pandemic
but today the new u.s climate normals
have been released
now they're 30-year averages of key
climate observations
and are the basis for judging how
temperature rainfall and other
conditions compare to what's normal for
a given location
in today's climate and what's clear is
that we're experiencing
a new warmer normal and you can see here
the u.s
annual average temperature during each
normals period
compared to the 20th century average
places where the annual temperature
during a given era was
colder than average a blue places where
the temperature was warmer than average
are red and the influence of long-term
global warming
is obvious as we move through the
decades the earlier years have the most
widespread and darkest blues
and then if we look at the maps for the
latter half of the century
you can see how the difference from the
average is warming up with the most
recent map having the most
widespread and darkest reds
now one place where the those warmer
temperatures are being
felt right now is in california and
almost all of the state is now
officially experiencing drought
with much of it classified as extreme
in marin county mandatory water
restrictions have been imposed
and greg milam has been seeing the
impact of the drought
at phoenix lake reservoir north of san
francisco
at the sharp end of the very real
climate crisis
this is phoenix lake up here north of
san francisco this is one of the seven
reservoirs that supplies
almost all of the water to this part of
california known as marin county and you
don't need to be an expert to look out
there and see what's going on the water
level in this reservoir
they say is about 30 of where it should
be in a normal year
you look up those caked banks of mud
there cracked and the
heat here and the water should be up at
the level of that
that the tree line there at the level of
the grass but it is that extreme
situation historic drought here they say
is playing out just as an illustration
where i'm standing in a normal year my
feet would be
under water the water would would lap up
over the edge of the reservoir into this
reed bed and down into the spillway
across this region
the reservoirs are at 50 percent and
that's why they've taken this drastic
action they say of mandatory water
restrictions
on the 200 000 people who live in marin
county they can't power wash their
houses or driveways they can't wash
their cars at home
they can't fill their swimming pools and
hot tubs
because they say this action is needed
ahead of of course what's to come which
will be the hot dry months
of summer and when you look at what the
us government scientists are saying
about the climate change future of
america for a lot of people here
it's already a modern day reality in
today's other climate news the uk
and india have announced a joint
agreement to combat climate change the
countries will work together in areas
including clean energy
and protecting forests it comes as
foreign ministers from the world's
leading economies are taking part in
face-to-face meetings at the g7 summit
in london
the group will discuss how to help
vulnerable countries cope with the
impact of climate change
[Applause]
politicians in france are due to vote on
a new climate law which has been
criticized by environmental groups
it includes measures that would ban some
domestic flights
and put restrictions on renting out
badly insulated houses
campaigners say the bill doesn't go far
enough given the pace
of climate change globally
and uber is working with startup company
arrival
to produce electric taxis the two
companies want to create a greener car
that will use uber's app
to automatically match passengers with
cars that have
sufficient battery range arrivals senior
vice president tom elvidge
says they aim to start producing the
taxis by the end
of 2023. now you may remember
last month 40 world leaders came
together a president biden's
climate change summit and the pledges
that were made there
including new targets on cutting
emissions have changed
how much scientists think our world will
warm by the end of the century
so here's where we are at the moment at
just above 1.2 degrees of
warming and that number is going up all
the time and scientists estimate that a
current rate
this is the amount of time left until we
hit
1.5 degrees so here's the updated
climate action
tracker predictions for the rest of the
century and they estimate that
if there's full implementation of the
net zero targets that have been
announced or
being considered global warming by 2100
could be as low as two degrees now
that's the optimistic target
scenario and is still far above the 1.5
degrees committed to
at the paris agreement in 2015.
if we then look at current pledges and
targets those are
unconditional commitments that
governments have made and officially
submitted to the un
it's thought that there'll be 2.4
degrees of warming by 2100 that's
0.2 degrees cooler than before the biden
summit
now if no change was made to policies
that are currently in place around the
world it's estimated that global warming
will be as high as nearly
three degrees by the end of the century
now phasing out coal as a power source
is going to be crucial in keeping those
global temperature rises
below 1.5 degrees but a new report has
found
the british bank's financial support for
companies involved in the coal industry
has actually increased since the 2015
paris agreement so uk investors provided
loans and underwriting services worth
nearly
22 billion pounds to coal companies
during 2019. now that's an increase of
nearly 16 billion pounds
compared with figures for 2016 and it
makes the uk the third
largest investor in the coal industry
after the united states and japan
and many british banks have pledged to
address their climate policies
and stop financing coal projects despite
that
reclaimed finance says the uk's top 10
financial firms are responsible for 78
of the country's total coal investments
well our business correspondent paul
kelso
joins me now so paul just how much
pressure
are banks under to reduce their
investments in coal projects
there's political pressure we heard
secretary of state anthony blinken tell
economies that were still investing in
new coal that they would be in his words
hearing from the united states
but there's pressure around the way coal
is financed
coming in the shape of this report and
indeed from the bank's
own commitments to green not just their
businesses but their investments and the
reason people are looking at the city of
london
is because no matter what you burn power
generators need money and the city of
london is
built on great reserves of finance and
how that finance
is deployed will have a great impact on
whether climate commitments can be
met now this report shows that british
banks are investing still
heavily in coal around the world
bangladesh indonesia south korea
korea some of it indeed going into
companies that the campaigners say
fund new coal developments which is
something coming at a time when
there's general agreement coal has to be
phased out but half of that funding is
coming via barclays like many banks
it has committed to greening its
investment book but it has said
that the best way to do that is to fund
the transition to clean
energy rather than just withdrawing the
funding
to coal power now campaigners will say
that's quite a
good way of also ensuring that balance
sheets at banks
don't get hit and ultimately
shareholders and indeed perhaps
investors
won't lose out the truth is that as long
as there is coal being
generated as long as there is profit as
well as power
in funding coal the city of london and
other financial centres
are going to retain an interest in
investing in it
paul thank you now when you think of
nature helping to tackle climate change
forests full of trees sucking in carbon
dioxide
probably come to mind but far more
carbon is stored in the seas around the
uk
than in the forests on land and a new
report published today
is calling on the government to treat
re-wilding the oceans
with the same level of urgency as
reforestation
here's why the sea is so important in
fighting climate change
in 60 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well joining me now is marine
conservation analyst kelly forsythe
so kelly forsyth just how important are
our oceans for storing carbon
often when people think about carbon
storage the first thing that comes to
mind is forests
and whilst forests all over the world um
do play an important role in carbon
storage so does the ocean
so the oceans cover about 70 percent of
the earth's surface
our oceans are actually the world's
largest carbon sinks
the ocean and its ecosystems such as
seagrass meadows
marshes and mangrove forests play a
really vital role in capturing carbon
under actually known as blue carbon
systems however
the oceans are also home to tiny
microscopic plants called phytoplankton
so like other plants phytoplankton are
able to change carbon dioxide into
oxygen
through a process known as
photosynthesis this is particularly
important as carbon dioxide is a
greenhouse gas
meaning that it contributes
significantly to global warming
sea surface temperature and ultimately
climate change
these tiny plants are the backbone of
the marine food chain
and end up being eaten by zooplankton or
tiny microscopic animals which then
get eaten by fish and the chain goes on
and on
eventually resulting in about 10 billion
tons of carbon
being transferred from the atmosphere
into the different layers of the ocean
so phytoplankton alone are responsible
for providing around 50
of the oxygen in our atmosphere which is
around the same amount as all of the
plants
on land now before we go we've just got
time to show you the real-time power mix
in great britain
and today a huge 63 of electricity is
coming from renewable
sources at the moment and that's in part
because of the blustery weather that
we've been seeing across the country
according to the national grid a new
wind power record was set yesterday
with 17.6 gigawatts of power generated
providing nearly 50
of electricity and that's everything
from us
for today on the daily climate show
tomorrow find out how much
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
could affect sea levels around the world
see you then
you